just journeying up to the angada
mountains as a sublime experience as is
crossing the Juliet pass at an altitude
of over 2,000 meters a more leisurely
option is to take the bernina express
the trains been ferrying passengers up
and down the mountain since 1910 while
some trains run through UN World
Heritage Sites the Bernina line actually
is one thanks to its combination of
stunning views and civil engineering
those traveling to the mountains from
Italy crossed the bernina pass where the
Train gets its name from been wanting to
do this for two years and we finally
made it it's really very nice
the ride also takes us to sanctum elites
known around the world as a holiday
destination for the rich and famous
it's the best-known city in the region
and also the highest in Europe at 1,800
meters altitude it's a perfect location
for winter sports lovers the resorts
here in the anga D offers skiers and
snowboarders some of the best slopes in
the world
for those not interested in scheme there
are plenty of other thrills available
you can take a bobsled ride with
professionals for 230 euros on Europe's
oldest natural run course there's room
for two guests in a four-person bobsled
for visitors while the other two places
are taken by experts but only people
looking for a serious adrenaline rush
should take part the sled travels almost
as fast as competitors in the Olympic
Games the anang is about 1722 metres
long and it'll take us one minute 13
seconds to cover that we will reach a
top speed of 100 36 or 37 kilometres an
hour that's about 10 to 12 kilometers
per hour slower than in a racing bobsled
bobsledders performance can't be
overestimated he brought us down safely
it was phenomenal
the landscape here has been an
inspiration to artists and architects
such as Norman Foster who designed the
chesa Futura and some of its other
architects try to combine modern designs
with traditional local style this
apartment building in Punta Sina created
by Hans Eureka is the perfect example
than Hamid fish heed the knee soon we
have various traditional elements of an
old-fashioned farmhouse but we've also
got a new interpretation with these
funnel-shaped windows and we presented
the place in a modern way the Tongass
test there are plenty of other examples
of typical Engadine farmer's homes in
Punta Sina
he faints descending Basayev Klein get
all the windows are always kept very
small and to maximize the amount of
light coming in these funnels were
developed you can see them very nicely
here Suzie and sis Mejia was where 19th
century philosopher Friedrich Nietzsche
would come to rest and ruminate home to
700 people it's considered one of the
prettiest villages in the region since
1908 a distinctive palatial looking
building has towered over SILS MA via
the White House his hotel has attracted
an eclectic mix of celebrities over the
past century ranging from Thomas Mun to
David Bowie it's been run by the same
family for five generations
as far as we'll do what we need the
Bauhaus was initially built for the
summer and then in 1924 was set up for
winter - I nowadays forget about 60% of
our guests in the winter the rest in
summer the last stop on our tour is a
ride up to mow artists Mahon a funicular
railway
the location boasts great views across
the Engadine Valley from an altitude of
almost two and a half thousand meters to
see it at its most spectacular visitors
should check out the views at sunset